We need kong the world needs him
it's godzilla
this is our only chance
we have to take it
we need kong the world needs
him to stop what's coming
and this child she's the only
one he'll communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had nowhere
to go so i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way kong did the same
it's godzilla
these are dangerous times godzilla's out there
and he's hurting people and we don't know why
there's something provoking him that we're
not seeing here with the same opinion
the myths are real there was a war
and they're the last one standing
kong bows to no one
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new godzilla versus kong trailer video they just
dropped another new one just a couple days ago
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're doing an
amazon giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your theories
about who winds up winning during the movie
there have been all kinds of rumors about them
changing the ending depending on whether or not
they're going to renew their license with touhou
and make more godzilla and kong more vs movies
for the most part all the rumors about that
are actually pretty good that they will wind up
renewing their license and we'll see more monster
versus movies they're actually doing a new netflix
anime series set on skull island too so that just
bodes well that they're going to continue to do
more projects in the monster verse i'll talk about
that at the end of the video too like where do
we go in the monster verse with the movies after
godzilla vs kong if we're already doing something
with mechagodzilla during this we also got
confirmation on some of the names of the titans
that they're changing during the movie which
other titans show up during these trailers but
in the new trailer footage they focus a lot more
on the scenes between this little girl in kong the
kong whisper the alexander skarsgard is arguing
with rebecca hall about like we have to take her
with us she's the only one he responds to they
haven't really made her origin clear in the movie
she might be a member of the tribe or a member of
a group that got stranded on skull island at some
point and she just formed some relationship with
him it had been implied in the last movie that a
lot of people had either been stranded there or
were living there as natives so there's a lot
of different reasons why she could have wound up
growing up there a couple people did clarify what
the deal is with him being called kong and not
king kong though that's actually because of some
legal dispute some copyright issue that prevents
them from using the king kong name in the movie
but during the last kong movie they did have that
line of dialogue saying that kong is king around
here so they have referenced him as king kong even
if they can't legit call him that during the movie
there's a lot more scenes of their first fight on
the ships here footage of godzilla just straight
up destroying or capsizing the ship that kong
is standing on here he goes into the water and
they want to hype it up like he's drowning but
if you haven't seen the classic 1960s king kong
versus godzilla film a lot of this is riffing on
some moments from that kong does know how to swim
they're just hyping this part of the fight up
for drama because we've seen the godzilla is
just as powerful in the water as he is on land he
uses that ancient underwater coverage system to
travel quickly around the world like an underwater
expressway system fast pass and we've only ever
really seen this version of kong fight when he's
got ground to stand on even in the lakes and the
rivers that he walks around on in skull island
he's so big that they're like puddles to him so
the idea is that godzilla would have a natural
advantage in deep water where kong's center of
gravity is upended and at this point in the movie
it doesn't seem like kong has this battle axe yet
but as you can see in some of the other trailer
footage you see kong get a couple good swipes
in like he's got those twin pythons on him and
he does not skip leg days whereas godzilla has
those stubby little arms and has to make up for
a lack of traditional brawling skills with his
big tail swipes and special energy attacks
like his atomic breath of the nuclear pulse
or his super strong armor scales so really what
kong would need to do is just get godzilla in a
grapple and then take him down before godzilla
has time to charge any of his special abilities
but the way the rest of this first fight goes down
it seems like godzilla is able to get a really
good swipe in and just cold clock kong almost like
a tko in godzilla is the clear winner of this boat
fight which seems like it's from pretty early in
the movie then in the new trailer there's a couple
other new fight scenes there might actually be
three different fight scenes in the trailer here
because there's a bunch more footage of the hong
kong fight where godzilla lands this solid tail
swipe on kong and knocks him through a couple
high rises but then there's completely different
looking scenes of kong in the daylight after a
fight looking like he's been knocked out cold by
godzilla or mechagodzilla and it's hard to tell
if this is after the same hong kong fight or a
totally different one they really really want you
to think that kong gets his ass beat in this movie
from all the ways they've cut this trailer it just
feels like a total misdirect though like clearly
the little girl here gives him some epic pep talk
and he revives like you see him stand up and start
screaming amidst all this rubble in the daylight
like this is meant to be a big rally moment for
him the way that godzilla had a big rallying
moment during godzilla king of monsters against
ghidorah but it's really hard to tell if this
fight scene is from the end of the movie because
sometimes studios will do that surprisingly like
you wouldn't think that they would give away the
ending of the movie but i think the way they've
cut this they're just trying to be as misleading
as possible about when this is actually happening
there's been all kinds of competing rumors about
who winds up winning this fight depending on
what happens with future godzilla and kong films
future monster verse films but like i said i think
it's all good news like they will continue to use
these characters in the future and if you didn't
watch the classic 1960s king kong vs godzilla film
the funny thing about that is that there are
actually two different versions of the movie
and depending on which version of the movie you
watch a different monster winds up winning the
fight are seeming like they come out on top but
really the movie winds up ending in a kind of
ambiguous way with both kong and godzilla
going their separate ways like you see him
swimming off here back to skull island so we might
wind up with a similar situation with godzilla
versus kong because i think we're all expecting
them to do the big tag team against mechagodzilla
take that down and then maybe they go their
separate ways we also get a little more footage of
kong with his special acts they're just calling it
a battle axe here but it looks like it's made from
one of the bones of maybe a mudo and obviously
godzilla's dorsal spike and it can absorb his
atomic breath making it even more powerful and in
the way that they're giving kong this new special
weapon they're giving godzilla new special attacks
during the movie too but that might have something
to do with maybe a magnetic base attack because
of mechagodzilla something to help him fight
mechagodzilla but according to the movie the whole
idea with mechagodzilla is that apex creates it as
a way to end what they're calling the reign of the
monsters so to speak because the way they've been
canonizing the monsters in the ancient history of
the earth with these ancient cultures that worship
them like gods is that humanity is basically
like the pets of the monsters so whereas during
godzilla king of monsters you have all these
eco-terrorists running around the world trying
to unleash the monsters on the earth to return
it to this natural state apex as an organization
seems like it wants to end the reign of the
monster so to speak maybe also profit off them
quite a bit the way they hyped it up during king
of monsters is that there are so many different
things that you can do with titan biology you can
create weapons medicines pretty much anything you
could possibly imagine but some of the other
new titans that they've confirmed just based
on the way they're selling these toys here they
have skull crawler toys that they're selling for
the movie so maybe there's some flashbacks with
skull crawlers to the events of kong skull island
or maybe we see some new ones during the movie
these titans that you see him swinging around
on skull island are now being called war bats the
snake-like flying titans the ones that look like
the classic bat titans in the trailer they're just
calling those hell hawks the secret one that's all
covered up the exclusive a is probably a version
of mechagodzilla just based on the outline
an exclusive b might be a logo or a patch designed
for apex or it could be another mystery titan
but in terms of the future of the monsterverse
movies like where do we go after godzilla vs kong
there's always the idea that they do another like
full-blown battle royale war of the monsters like
they keep referencing this ancient war of the
monsters they could be building up to a bigger
version of that and if they don't want to escalate
things to a full-blown war of the monsters yet
they could just introduce other big titans they
haven't done yet like destoroyah there were also
a lot of rumors about them thinking about doing
crossovers with the pacific rim franchise because
that's another legendary franchise but if they
wanted to get that crazy with it they probably
have to shift the time period to the future so you
wouldn't have millie bobby brown or a lot of the
characters from present day in those movies they
have to introduce a brand new cast but everyone
post all your theories about godzilla versus
kong on the video and let me know what do you
want them to do with future monster verse movies
i've got some new Wandavision that i'm working on
my Wandavision episode 7 video will also post
friday they're also going to be releasing the
first big mortal kombat movie trailer tomorrow
so i'll be doing a video for that as well
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of those you can click here
for my Wandavision episode 7 trailer video and you
can click here for that brand new justice league
snyder cut trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!